about another hour and 15 minutes we'll
be live today at the Miami Book Fair
International it's in downtown Miami on
the campus of miami-dade College you can
see phone numbers there on the screen
that's because John Ralston Saul is
joining us to do a call-in show you just
saw his presentation along with George
Packer 202 is the area code for all of
our numbers if you support the Democrats
737 triple zero one is the number for
you to call if you support President
Bush 737 triple zero 2 is the number for
you to call and two zero two six two
eight zero two zero five four all others
we only have a few minutes with our
guests the book TV bus is in the middle
of the street fair here at the Miami
Book Fair and inside the bus is John
Ralston Saul he is the author of this
book the collapse of globalism mr. Saul
would most people agree with you that
globalism is collapsing I think most
people haven't thought about it I mean
you know the argument has been dominated
by the for and against I mean you know
we had 25 years of the four and then
increasingly we've had the voices of the
against and most people are sort of
right up close in the in the battle if
you like almost like shadows of each
other and nobody's really either been
smart or stupid enough to stand back
from it and say you know if you actually
look at this thing we can see it coming
in Y we can see it rising and then I
think I'd say 90 95 it's my take on then
you can see it starting to decline you
can see the wheels falling off the bus
as I said earlier and and you can start
to see the world slipping into a kind of
confused state going in no particular
direction but a whole bunch of
directions at once what I call a you
know the confused vacuum between two
eras and I think that's where we are
today you also talk about nationally
what I do I agree with you that it's you
know I'm out there and sometimes I was
at a university here yesterday and a
bunch of bright people they never heard
this argument before but they were
bright so they started reacting to it
nationalism in China particularly what's
there well I think you know China the
West has always tried to project onto
China what it wanted to project onto it
we're very bad at sort of saying well
one of the Chinese actually saying among
themselves what do they think they're
doing why do they think they're doing
things and because we don't actually
ever ask ourselves that question we just
keep doing what we did it time of the
opium wars in the nineteenth century or
the British did in the 18th century we
just sort say this is what the Chinese
are doing and you know you go and ask
Chinese and they think they're actually
rebuilding the Middle Kingdom they think
they've got some real problems inside
they have to move really fast they're
not particularly interested in Western
economic theories which we say are
global which they think are Western
they've got their own ideas you may like
them you may dislike them but they're
their own ideas about how to do
economics and how to organize society
any of their own problems and the
reinvention of the world is a subtitle
of this book our first call for our
guest is Philadelphia you're on the air
go ahead Adelphia you with us go ahead
yes John number one I'm going to buy
your book I also read the world was flat
and the conclusion I came after reading
that book was it in a perfect world yes
globalization can work but we live in
such an imperfect world and my question
to you is I've been following gold for a
long time and what I've come to realize
is lately the gold is acting the inverse
of what it normally does when oil goes
up goeb would go up when the dollar was
weak gold would go up it's doing the
inverse now and I think that showing me
signs that the the world is starting to
see this instability and the wheels
falling off I just want to get your
thoughts on it because I truly think
that there's a lack of faith and world
currencies and chaos mmm
that go to me it's going to go to 600
hours by next year and just just I just
look at that as a barometer of sentiment
and just want to get your thoughts on it
Thank You caller that's really
interesting question actually I think
that you know one of the things that has
been said more and more by all sorts of
economists and bankers and so on of all
stripes for the last well certainly in
the last decade is that the financial
situation there nationally is not
sustainable I mean this is the most
repeated thing about International
Economics it's not sustainable
so far it's lasted but you know at a
certain point history tells us that
stuff like this if it's not solid does
collapse and I suppose it's an
interesting argument to say that you
know gold be strengthening that way
certainly that's not what should be
happening if you know if globalization
were actually working working gold would
not be going up as if you were in the
middle of somewhere in the 19th century
and that people were hold you know
dependent on gold for a belief in
stability I mean the old saying of the
French putting their gold underneath
their mattresses and all that stuff
we're almost in an era like that I mean
I sometimes think we're in 1750 I
sometimes think we're in the 1930s I
mean they're the this is not the
postmodern era that it's described as
it's got some it's got some elements of
you know the South Sea Bubble the John
lauve financial collapse era you know
it's it's a very difficult era to get
your finger on and certainly it is not
the ER that was predicted in the 70s 80s
and 90s where do you put Walmart in that
era well I mean you know I think we have
to wait it's one of those things where
you probably have to wait 10 years to be
certain it is possible that when we look
back in 10 years you'll have seen that
Walmart was very much a character of the
globalist era that it made sense in this
rather bizarre period in which people
thought that the most important human
rights were low taxes and cheap goods
whereas in fact and maximum profits
whereas in fact the history of
capitalism is that you have to have
reasonable profits and reasonable levels
of taxes and reasonable prices because
you don't have reasonable prices you
can't pay your workers you know if I
think I mentioned in Walmart I don't
know it was a 10 or a dozen pairs of
underwear in the United States for $7
well you know
no American worker can earn a living as
a dignified citizen of the United States
if the goods they're producing are sold
at that wage so that that is not
actually a capitalist model the
capitalist model is that you get going
in the prices have to rise enough to be
able to pay wages to give the stability
which is required for middle-class
democracy so I think people may look
back on it and think that it was just a
peculiar phenomenon of this short-lived
sort of lunacy which was a belief and
you know that economics was going to
determine the shape of the world very
quickly short lived beginning when well
short lived I think you know you can see
the it really starts you don't put dates
on it it really starts with Nixon
devaluing the American dollar so it's at
72 71 or 73 if I get now and you know at
that point you get a kind of a break
with the Keynesian period and then in
the confusion the neoconservative
neoliberal globalist rush in and fill
the space and the the reigning elite
fails in the crisis Peoria Illinois on a
Republican line you're on with John
Ralston Saul go ahead Peoria hello Pete
go ahead Peoria no this is Alabama ok
Alabama hi Alabama I just want to read
back I just wanted to go Republican for
Bush ok well thank you for your call we
appreciate that Reno Nevada
good afternoon your own book TV Reno
with us yes I'm with you can you hear me
go ahead with your comment please ok mr.
Saul you mentioned racism as a thematic
upon returning from Europe
it wasn't exactly clear to me what you
meant but I was wondering whether you
could touch on the question of European
identity within the theme of this
collapse of glow blue when I think you
had you know what's fasting and I'm a
big supporter of Europe and I'm Canadian
by because I think Europe is a fantastic
the project is a fantastic project the
difficulty was that you know after the
war the same World War when they started
putting it together the elites kind of
lost the courage they thought the
easiest way to do this is
as top down so let's do the
administration let's integrate the
economy let's do some political stuff
and the rest will follow well of course
they found themselves a half century
later with this really brilliant
experiment in place and they suddenly
realize that they even though
technically it was all democratic they
hadn't done that thing which happens
inside a nation-state which is there
really hadn't been any discussion among
the citizens there there's virtually no
program in Europe to move schoolkids
around so there's one elite program the
Erasmus program the university level but
you know they're taking school kids and
moving them into other countries for a
month so they get to know you know
German kid gets to know what French kids
lives are like and what it's really like
sort of thing now that they're going to
become French but that they're able as
philosophers say to imagine the other
they didn't do any of that so they find
themselves semi integrated from the
power point of view in the
administrative point of view and totally
disintegrated from the human point of
view so at a certain point which is in a
sense the point of the at the beginning
of the breakdown of globalization you
get of course the beginning of a stall
in Europe and not surprising the people
who made the wrong decisions in Europe
about let's do it from the top and leave
out the people were among the leaders of
the globalist movement people like
Schmidt and just gotta stand so so sorry
but the more specific answer to your
question is that that that they were on
the edge and I think it's may be gone
forever we'll see they were on the edge
of a very interesting experiment which
was getting rid of the old idea of the
nation-state the 19th century 18th
century idea of the nation-state
which brought all those murders the 20th
century disasters all the rest of it and
going back to something that you could
call the Erasmus idea the the high
middle ages at its best which is
multiple borders multiple loyalties
multiple existences multiple
personalities and you know people
Europeans would have a
multiple-personality order you know
instead of a multiple personality
disorder so that you could say well I'm
actually from the Mediterranean that's a
real culture Provence or Italy or
Barcelona I'm from France
I'm from Western Europe I'm from
southern Europe and these are all real
loyalties and that's a new kind of
existence going back to an old
experiment I unfortunately I think that
the rise of classical nationalism means
that we may have lost it again what's
your view about the u.s. well you
probably have a more interesting
statement that I would I mean I think
it's you know this is an amazing country
and it's a country which has always had
I mean I noticed you have people calling
in as according to their memberships
into political parties but but from a
historical in a philosophical point of
view this is a country which has two
great traditions which aren't asleep I
did by those two parties in fact it's
changed around and and they're really
there's the great humanist tradition the
Enlightenment some of the very great the
noble ideas of the origin of the United
States and then there's the nationalist
United States so you know the the
Jacksonian early 19th century thing and
since the run our early 1830s or so the
cut-the-knot states goes back and forth
between the two them it's never clear
but what is I suppose seems to be
happening now as the United States seems
to be entering into one of those
nationalist phases in fact it's in it
and that's one of the signs of the
collapse and globalism is that when when
the most powerful country in the world
becomes very nationalistic of course
it's a message to the rest of the world
it's okay to be really nationalistic so
there was the beginning of globalization
you see this decline of the idea of
nationalism and here 25 35 years later
you see nationalism coming back and at
the core of it is the greatest nation in
the world you know the most powerful the
leader of the idea of democracy living
itself engaging in seeing itself in
nationalistic terms so that's you know
that's a very interesting thing to think
about
our guest is John Ralston Saul here his
here is his book the collapse of
globalism Montville New Jersey you're on
the air go ahead please yes hello I have
to quick but disparate questions for dr.
Saul one is what would is his take on
the source of momentum behind engaged
in China policy going back to the very
late 80s and early 90s I have my own
suspicions
what is the source of what is sorry what
is the source of the momentum caller to
doing the hole okay you have engagement
of course you know getting China first
of all into GATT and then of course
getting rid of the yearly most favored
nation vote etc and then to where we are
now I have my own suspicions about where
the source of the momentum behind that
is but I'll leave that to you the second
is what do you feel about self-policing
or self-regulation when we look at
something like Enron for example when we
established an energy market and it was
allowed to police itself and we quickly
devolved to the lowest common
denominator ethically resulting and of
course what we've all seen in the late
90s of the debacle excuse me in 2001
with Enron um Thank You caller I got the
point
doctor the second point first it you
know a big mistake was made in Western
civilization how's that for in her
narrow start which was to confuse
commercial contracts with social
contracts and there are two separate
things and you know criminal law the law
that has to do with us as real people is
is it you know is written in order to
deal with the two three four percent of
the population who will perhaps break
the law the assumption in all
civilizations is that ninety-five
percent of the population will do the
right thing whether the law exists or
not so in other words you have to stay
away either in a decent civilization
from the idea that the reason laws are
there is everyone will run amok if you
don't have the laws they don't run amok
because if they did run amok I mean
you'd have all sorts of things happening
that aren't having commercial law is a
completely different matter once you're
in an area where you're not talking
about the public good but you're talking
about self-interest
now you no longer have a fundamental
ethical limit on what can happen that
doesn't mean it's a bad thing self if
yourself is an essential part of our
civilization but we've known we have
always known it goes right back to the
Greeks Peck it goes back beyond the
Greeks it goes back to you know
Gilgamesh
you have us I mean it tigris and
euphrates that that the free market
works best when it is cleanly and
effectively and efficiently regulated by
regulating it in a neat and tidy way
which is a key point you actually
liberate the market to be more
competitive and for greater profits to
be made and for wealth to be created
where you deregulate it too much and
this is you're always searching for the
bounce when you do over deregulate what
you get is your Enron situation there is
no way in which a private sector can
regulate itself and I'm not making a
comment about the United States or
Canada am I going to comment about 4,000
years of history I mean there's no
civilization in the history of the world
which has believed for any length of
time that the marketplace can regulate
itself it does not exist and no serious
economist has ever proposed it and I can
tell you that someone like Adam Smith
who is you know the most misquoted man
in the history of the world I would say
mainly by economists who don't read Adam
Smith to quote him and they read they
read the kind of excerpts that suit them
but they don't really read Adam Smith me
allison's would go mad at the idea that
this the private sector was supposed to
regulate so they say are you fools are
you naive I mean are you crazy
of course it's not going to work out so
the trick is can you have neat tidy fast
efficient regulations that allow it to
go so and that was one of the delusions
of the globalist period that because the
nation-state was going to weaken
therefore economics at the international
level we're going to take over and they
could not be regulated and therefore the
right marketplace would have to regulate
itself that was the theory but of course
it was a bogus theory because in fact
you know as I said in my talk there are
many many examples of nation-states or
groups in nation-states regulating
things I mean in fact you're very
impressive antitrust group having lost
its courage for quite a few years has
got it back and is doing a pretty
effective job in fact you've just
indicted a former Canadian citizen
Conrad Black shown that you're way ahead
of the Canadians and the British who
could have done it years ago so I mean
you know the the second issue was what
drives the canoe
the China thing I think one is what I
said it earlier which is we're always
pretending China something it's what we
want it to be as opposed to what it
really is and so we're always saying god
if we only get China in if we could only
get China to do things our way and we
never sort of ask ourselves well you
know what is it China wants to do what's
China up to and so when when the moment
comes were were shocked as as the
globalists have been very shocked in the
last six months when they suddenly you
know they said we're sure China coming
into globalism and then they suddenly
look up there in this little valley of
true belief and they look up and they
see I don't know a trillion tons of
goods dropping on their heads and they
say oh my god that's not we meant by
globalization you know you you got four
tariffs on yourselves you got to you got
to put your currency up in it and the
Chinese say you said you wanted us to do
it your way we're doing it your way
so then you discover that what what
really it was about was that our people
in the West the United States Canada
France Germany we were in favor of
globalization borderless globalization
providing the headquarters were in the
West as soon as we discover that the
headquarters are going to be in China we
don't like him so then we start putting
the brakes on and now I mean there's
some specific questions it has to do
with you know jobs but they should have
thought of that it wasn't rocket science
to know that once you brought the
barriers down it you know it's the
Walmart question we couldn't produce the
underwear at those prices because we
want to have public schools you know we
want to have various kinds of health
care we want to have a middle class
Society so there's no way we could be we
knew that I mean if these tenured
economists and these heads of
corporations and these senior civil
servants took till now to figure this
out they're really in trouble they put
us in trouble
Cape May New Jersey you're on with John
Ralston Saul go ahead Kate may go ahead
please dr. role you are a very very
brilliant man and I agree with
brilliance everything you say I have a
bad cold you are a very brilliant man
and I agree with everything you say I
would like to know if you think
well before what I'd like to know is how
low do you think and how much trouble do
you think the United States will have to
get into with the wheels for the wheels
fall off and it will we ever do you
think there's any chance that we will
ever elect an honest man like a Ralph
Nader type Thank You caller dr. Saul
well I think the the the big question
for the United States and I could be
wrong about this you don't say the big
question is this sort of double debt
situation on the one hand the internal
debt
which you know has been created really
taken up to a whole serious level in the
last few years and then the
international debt which of course China
is a key player in the combination of
these two things and I'm designing
original what I'm saying this is a big
problem for the United States are
therefore the world let's face it I mean
if the Unites States is a big problem
the world's got a big problem and I
don't know how you or any of us get out
of it you know it's not going to be I
mean you could improve it slightly by
cutting you know cutting back seriously
on government spending but then you
create other problems depending on what
you cut right because it's some real
poverty problems and some real education
problems so if you start cutting in that
area you're actually creating a bigger
long-term problem so the only place
you've got to cut is the military and I
have absolutely no idea that's your
affair whether you want to cut in that
area or not but you don't actually have
in the social area much you can cut
without provoking other long-term social
and economic problems so
you know Nixon tried to deal with an
international problem like that by
devaluing the American dollar that's and
that provoked some serious inflation and
drop in growth it is conceivable that a
presidential candidate or a president
might turn around sometime in the next
five to ten years and say you know we're
the most powerful country in the world
we've got this army and we only have 15%
of our GDP which is international trade
so we're really not dependent on the
world interestingly enough from trade
point of view you know compared to
Canada or Germany or em you're not a big
trader
it's of zero and economy you could just
I mean they might just decide to slash
the dollar I mean the others they might
try one of the three or four methods
there are for getting rid of this debt
but because it's simply unserviceable
can't deal with any more and then then
we're probably into a protectionist
close border:0 if that happens so that's
that's the big risk so if you actually
kind of just listen to what people are
saying and what people keep saying is
the financial markets are unstable the
debt situation is unmanageable this is
really a problem and you mean it's not
just me I mean all sorts of people are
saying that from right to left and
nothing is being done which is even
heading in the direction of dealing with
that
so I actually haven't answered your
question and I actually don't know what
the answer is frankly I think it's a big
problem really big problem but what it
indicates is that the globalists theory
is on it is very seriously on its way
out well on page 147 oh my god of your
book you say that the most obvious
failure of globalization has been its
capacity to maintain employment right
the u.s. is around 5 a little over 5% on
employer Germany France 10 to 12% right
I'm not sure I think Canada's doing
quite well right semester number we've
had in years yeah so put that together
well let me put it through this way and
numbers are very tricky as we know
you know in fact you know I just look at
them all I think oh my god who's lying
or what works here
the OECD base numbers more or less are
that in 1970 we're beginning of
globalization we were at about ten
million unemployed in the OECD and then
each decade it kind of goes up by seven
to ten million and today officially the
numbers are 40 40 million this is not
because new people join the OECD that's
not where the new unemployment comes
from by the way it comes in charlie out
of the old membership now so that's a
four times increase in unemployment at a
time when as I said in my talk you know
trade went up 22 times internet you know
financial markets exploded etc now
here's the key point
didn't say 40 million back mrs. Thatcher
in her time in office redefined
unemployment over 20 times each time she
was defining unemployment of course it
was very carefully getting numbers off
the list right you know this is not
employment this is semi-retirement this
is retraining this is right and I think
she has the record but I mean counted
the same the United States did the same
France did the same germ anew so the
real figures are probably closer to
about 50 60 million unemployed in the
OECD so these are remarkable numbers and
then that doesn't take into account the
fact that we moved from a middle-class
family with two children your average
middle-class family of the 50s and 60s
one bread weight earner being able to
support the family now they consumed
last but nevertheless you know usually a
man sometimes a woman was able to
support the wife and two children's a
simpler life but nevertheless today
those families have you know 1.5
children and the husband and the wife
work and they're having trouble so all
of the numbers about how it works have
have slipped in effect and you know as
you know you have a whole bunch of
people who don't appear at all in the
end
numbers who are doing two and three
part-time jobs unsecured and that's yet
another group who really didn't exist in
the same way in the 50s and 60s so the
numbers are actually quite worrying I
mean less saying they're unsustainable
but they're what they suggest is this
incredible dichotomy between
contradiction between the increase in
the money markets the increase in trade
and not real growth I mean if I were a
woman I'd be outraged I mean the biggest
change in the last 50 years and
certainly the last 35 years is that
women as a whole came into the workforce
so we had women being exploited cheap
labor etcetera earlier on in factories
but now we've got you know women on the
Supreme Court women on you know in the
United States can but the head of our
supreme courts a woman and we have I
think three women on the court I can
number how many you've got now but two
and you know women are doing all these
important jobs and they're at middle
levels and so on but in a way given the
numbers I've just
but the situation described you in this
period we have inflated away the real
wealth creation which the arrival of
women in the marketplace represents I
mean it is the most insulting thing done
to women in the twentieth century that
this enormous breakthrough was made in
getting women into the workforce at all
levels and then it's that you know not
cheap goods at Walmart that should have
represented like a 50% increase in real
real wealth creation and instead of that
it's been inflated away it's a very it's
a great failure for current economics in
just a few minutes the John Hope
Franklin event will begin next call for
John Ralston Saul comes from Herndon
Virginia in the Washington DC suburbs go
ahead Herndon high dog thought I was
calling because on two subjects that you
just had when you were talking about the
price of you know seven pairs of
underwear and the the manufacturing of
that it seemed like when I look in China
and there's a hidden numbers is the
middle-class dying in the United States
and really throughout
Thank You Carla well you know the
numbers say that there's a lot of
pressure on the middle middle class I
mean most of the numbers show that this
is the group that's having that that you
should have been the glory if you like
of Western democracies that we would all
become middle class and of course we'd
have you know unfortunately some people
who slipped through the barbed and of
course we'd have some people who slip
through the dog but that you know our
society would be like a diamond that the
big part of the society would be in the
middle and what we've seen in the
globalist period has been the exact
opposite which is a we're starting to
look more and more like a pyramid with
you know a little group at the top and
then this sort of bigger and bigger and
bigger as you move down and an enormous
pressure on the middle on on the middle
class and and I think I described some
of those things a lot of it's a sort of
hidden inflation which is not counted
and that I describe the situation of the
women's contribution is one of them
hidden inflation which is not counted
which means that were the the well slips
away the middle class stability slips
away and yet were unable to identify it
except that we feel it happening we
sense that it's happening and yet
nobody's counting the numbers in the
right way anymore so that we're using
very old-fashioned economic methods so
we can't really identify in this kind of
world what is happening to the middle
class except periodically they say you
know division between rich and poor is
getting bigger the collapse of globalism
is the book next called New Milford
Connecticut go ahead hi dr. Shaw like to
ask you about a book I read
confessions of an economic hitman by
John Perkins and his friend I read about
it I haven't read it yet okay his
premise was that we'd go into countries
developing countries in South America
the Middle East Iran being one and he
would put together a projection telling
them that they're going to have
tremendous growth of 20% or more and
they would contract with United States
companies or not just the United States
but big companies
build all kinds of infrastructure that
they really didn't need the projections
were too high that was his job within
these false projections then they would
default they would incurred that to
build these projects it was a fault on
the debt and US corporations would come
in they go over the projects that charge
for state water or different things
within these developing countries I just
want to get your opinion on that and how
things like that have affected the
global economy or if you think that
those things really happened if they did
how what was the effect to make global
government yeah I mean I haven't read
the book understanding of it is that
it's you know a pretty sharp view I
think he felt pretty negatively about
what had been happening and put it in
slightly more general terms I think that
now one of our characteristics is you
know we've done pretty well for
ourselves you know within the context so
up and down we really have a tendency to
want to tell other people what to do
when I say we I mean no no don't take it
personally I mean I think everybody in
Western civilization
seems to come out of the judeo-christian
tradition or something I don't know and
we're just endlessly finding new ways of
going into other continents and
basically saying that if they really
want to be happy they got to do it our
way and we're not you know the
fundamental philosophical idea and it's
not just Western is are you capable of
imagining the other the other is the
unknown not something you know not
something you necessarily like just the
other can you imagine them and imagine
the means that not that they're better
or worse note that their methods are
perhaps entirely acceptable but that
perhaps they have a geography a
tradition an approach which has some
good things in it and that if they're
going to find their way to the same
levels of stability and prosperity which
we've had at various times then they're
going to have to do it in a somewhat
different way they're not simply going
to do it by imitating us and somehow if
you look at the post Second World War
period I mean we went into Africa right
after the Second World War you know we
brought a lot of people to our countries
we educated and we sent them when we
went and said here's what you do we did
it it was a they did it was a mess then
we brought them back in and said
here's another way you have to do this
like we'd forgotten the first step and
now we're into the third stage of
telling Africa what to do you know and I
I was just in South Africa and I said to
people said you know be careful you
might find yourself leaping into the
globalist boat only to find a that it's
sinking and be that the West has already
jumped out and got in another boat and
we we have to learn to be more careful
with the way in which we try to save
other people and it I don't know what it
is I mean say say I look at the language
around Chinamen this is 19th century
language we're using we're not very good
at teaching about other traditions and
this doesn't mean that they don't have
enormous problems that they don't have
enormous things they need to change but
there has to be a way for them to change
it through their own logic you know and
that's something we have to learn to do
and we're with our advantages it's up up
to us not to insist that our way is the
only way that there have to be ways
within their way which will help them to
deal better with whether the issues are
whether it's the treatment of women or
the way they deal with their economy I
mean you know the marketplace well there
have always been marketplaces there have
always been forms of trade forms of
free-market
forms of regulation and we very and
often they are appropriate to the kind
of climate or civilization or religion
or ethics that this particular area has
and we could trace all of that so you
can't just sort of take you know what
works in London and say okay now this is
the way to do a financial market and go
to some completely different place maybe
that's not the way the good you know the
reason that Southeast Asia had his
meltdown in 97 was that we insisted that
the way to run a financial market was
our way and we actually destabilized
Southeast Asia by not paying attention
to the fact that they had a very high
savings rate because that's what they do
in those countries that that actually
they had great stability we said it was
crony capitalism
actually real capitalism is about people
knowing each other real owners actually
knowing each other that's how you run a
company that's what Adam Smith was in
favor of so we made this big argument
that what was wrong in Thailand and what
was wrong in Malaysia was crony
capitalism why because we moved past
that
and now have these large corporations
where nobody really owns them and
they're run by managers so we sort of
wanted them to have this disembodied
managerial system which wouldn't have
suited them at all
Voltaire's bastards and reflections of a
Siamese twin or a couple of the other
books that John Ralston Saul has written
Las Vegas go ahead with your question
yes I want to say this you're very
intelligent man and you actually should
have an hour-long show next to Oprah
educate us entertain it well you're
pretty educated another man
through and through moved here to this
town in 1984 work construction nine
years when I got up in the morning and I
went to work and I went to the store I
look for made in USA that means when I
got up in the morning at six o'clock my
fellow American working man was getting
up and going to work and producing
quality American goods the globalization
that you speak of I hope it does fail
and I hope America does not collapse in
the middle of it like the Romans the
Greeks the Egyptians and I disagree with
any democratic or Republican official
who run this country out of pure greed
and the fact that we deal with a
communist nation called China is going
to come back in my opinion to bite us I
don't believe in buying anything from
China but I don't have too much of a
choice anymore it seems now my point is
when are the wheels going to fall off or
when are the American people going to
get the wool pulled back above their
eyes and
with these goofy politicians that are
supposed to be run in this country to
protect the citizens what do you what do
you understand where I'm coming from
yeah I mean I think that there you know
in what you're saying there uh let me
say something you you you know you this
is an odd thing I'm going to say okay
most of the economic theories that we're
using today which you're describing
which have led us to the some of the
contradictions you're talking about
most of those economic theories were
invented in the 19th century
and one of the things about the 19th
century
you know Heights of capitalism and so on
was that we had a scarcity of goods you
know people couldn't go to the store and
see an enormous selection we were short
shoes we were short socks we were short
old glasses we were short food
everything was scarcity and the thought
was that if if we could use technology
and well-run competition with you know
half-decent regulations we could
actually through this mechanism drive
the economy forward and get more
production and get more goods right and
that that would be real growth and then
you know then I can set you with its ups
and downs in the early 20th century
that's what that's about but since the
Second World War the Western world you
know 20 odd democracies has been in
surplus you know we think about it I
mean one of the reasons that you know
we've got too much underwear you know
we've got too many socks got too many
soft drinks we've got too much food
we're just overflowing with surplus and
the problem is we're using an economic
theory which is all about scarcity and
so it's sort of it's a contradictory
system it simply doesn't work for the
West anymore and this is I think one of
the things that's driving prices down
it's one of the reasons where we keep
looking for cheaper ways to produce
goods in other countries there's nothing
wrong with the international production
but the purpose of international
production is not to undermine the
country to which you're bringing the
goods I mean that you should be able to
do international production and trade
without it creating you know a
disastrous situation for example for for
American workers that's not what's
supposed to happen
and the reason it seems to be happening
is because of this contradiction between
economics of scarcity and a reality of
surplus and it sort of creates this
impossible contradiction inside a place
like the United States I don't know if
that relates a little bit to tutu helps
a little in a way and it's it's nobody
else is saying this so God knows if I'm
right but I'm asking about it for quite
a while and I do think this is one of
them you know one of the problems
well Time magazine describes you as a
prophet so maybe you are right our guest
John Ralston Saul unfortunately has to
leave otherwise we'd keep him and have
him take a few more calls he's got to
catch a flight John Hope Franklin is
running late and we'll bring that event
to you as soon as it starts and that
will be live we're live here in Miami at
the Miami Book Fair International
miami-dade College downtown Miami and in
the meantime we want to show you the
southeastern bestseller list for this
week